good morning to you it is 5 13.
hopefully you should know this already
by now but distracted driving
it is no laughing matter yeah local
police are teaming up to make sure you
put down your phone
behind the wheel have you heard that
before on this program well that
reminded our eight news now friends at
night of a
certain someone's favorite catch phrase
remember it is against the law to drive
while using any
handheld electronic device in our state
so as nate tannebaum likes to say
put down that phone i love that nate got
his own bullet yeah how was my nate
tannenbaum
it was pretty good right you went kind
of deep with it too i like that
it was very stentorian and serious i
liked it
he adds a little more gruff to it put
down the phone
he doesn't know he's completely asleep
right now he knows they're they're
sleeping right now yeah
joke's on you nate impersonation
yes that's awesome so i think the only
thing denise really needed was a bow tie
yeah that was good nate can you show
us the the proper the original yes well
the junk is on traffic so i've got the
weather quicker while sheriff's office
do we need to switch you want to switch
be honest we don't have time for that
dude
let's pretend that that's okay so uh
buckle up
carefully and put down that phone
and thank you to daryl quick work back
there right there's the phone
my ringtone no no not at all
to find enough job but it's only it's
only real when it comes from nate
but it should be real for all of us all
the time of course